[Música]
segunda jornada consecutiva en Colombia
de protestas después de que en el día de
ayer fuesen Los partidarios de Gustavo
Petro en el día de hoy es la oposición
mayoritariamente de derechas que ha
salido para protestar contra las
reformas que el gobierno de Petro Busca
implementar en los próximos meses sobre
todo contra la de salud escuchamos a uno
de los organizadores de la marcha el año
pasado hicimos varias movilizaciones en
contra de las reformas buscando que se
retiraran y que se transformaran esas
reformas sin embargo Gustavo Petro lo
que hizo y el pacto histórico fue darle
la espalda al pueblo colombiano durante
toda la jornada hemos visto pancartas
con múltiples mensajes en contra de la
reformas sociales que quiera cometer el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro sobre todo con
miedo a que se pueda destruir el actual
sistema social de Colombia pero sobre
todo como pueden escuchar gritos contra
el presidente Gustavo Petro al que
muchos no reconocen por su pasado
guerrillero como esta manifestante que
habla de la paz Total que quiere en su
gobierno yo me pongo a la paz Total como
por concepto porque no es una paz ni es
total corresponde simplemente a una
política de acuerdos entre mafiosos y en
gente que no ha pagado ni resarcido los
perjuicios que ha tenido por la gravedad
de lo que le hicieron a Colombia y que
además incumplieron con un proceso de
paz jornada de catarsis en Colombia con
una oposición al gobierno de Gustavo
Petro y al propio presidente que han
salido a protestar contra sus reformas y
han llegado hasta esta céntrica Plaza de
Bolívar que han conseguido llenar unas
tres cuartas partes con miles de
personas precisamente detrás de mí está
el edificio del Congreso y detrás de
este congreso fue donde terminaron
también ayer las concentraciones en
favor del presidente Gustavo Petro en
dos jornadas pacíficas que muestran que
ni la oposición es tan fuerte pero
tampoco hay un apoyo tan masivo al
presidente Gustavo PE